[Music]
[Applause]
Dragonball super bro Lee is the latest
Dragonball film after battle of gods and
resurrection F and as most of you know
I'm a massive fucking fan of this
franchise TV show all of it love it good
shit check it out sometime if you
haven't bro Lee was always a fan
favorite in the movies but he was never
in the show there were three bro Lee
films there was a legendary super saiyan
second coming and bio bro Lee which most
of us like to forget exists but accurate
or Yama the creator of the franchise has
decided to make him a canon character
again and in this film we learn about
his past a little bit about Goku and
Vegeta's past leading to an epic fight
between Broly Vegeta and Goku for the
majority of 2018 the movies I was really
looking forward to seeing let me down
I mean sure there were some great
surprises like Spider Man into the
spider verse but I wasn't really
anticipating that film and it was nice
that it was so good but most of the
film's I was looking forward to were
disappointing and even into 2019 now the
same thing is happening so did the same
thing happened yet again with Dragon
Ball super bro Lee No finally a movie I
was excited for was actually good
obviously I've seen all the Dragon Ball
movies and while some of them are good
and some of them are bad one thing about
a lot of them is that they feel kind of
inconsequential and unimportant they
feel like these kind of offshoots some
of them are less than 50 minutes long
and they just feel sort of unnecessary
but in the case of this film it's a
hundred minutes there's a fleshed-out
story you learn about broglie's past
he's a real character with a real
background he doesn't feel like some
villain that's just there to scream and
punch things and even Goku and Vegeta
get a lot more to talk about and things
to be excited about you learn more about
the the past of the planet Vegeta you
see some stuff with Bardock I won't get
into any spoilers but I've always wanted
the movies to explore more of that the
past two films I have enjoyed but they
did feel sort of like fun offshoots that
didn't have that much impact on the
actual narrative this movie actually
tells a story that feels fleshed out I
actually kind of gave a shit about Broly
strangely he's not just some big hulking
machine like he has been in the past
they show his upbringing you actually
care about him a little bit and they do
a good job of making the ensuing battle
be not just one-sided you don't just
want to see Goku make a spirit mom and
throw it into Broly and that's the end
of the movie you actually are curious to
see what happens for these characters
because they give enough time to flesh
each character out even though I've seen
most of these people a billion times and
they've found a pretty good line to run
with Goku and Vegeta there's humor
that's balanced really well Vegeta is
afraid to show emotion and do anything
that might be considered embarrassing
and Goku is just really excited to fight
and yeah we've seen that before and
would you really want it any other way
though as a Dragon Ball fan of course
not what do you want go could a mope
around the whole movie I'd be stupid so
they actually did a pretty good job with
the characters in this one it wasn't
just a fanservice a Dragonball movie
yeah there's tons of stuff that you're
gonna love if you've been a fan for a
long time and things that are going to
excite you but they did actually put
forth effort into a compelling narrative
which surprised me in a very good way
this is a first time director for the
Dragon Ball franchise
he's never directed anything in the
Dragon Ball franchise before according
to IMDB and you can tell that he was
really trying to make his mark as far as
fight scenes go these are some of the
most impressive of scene in all of
Dragon Ball they're long they're fat
they're so fast actually I kind of lost
track a few times
seeing these battles on a big screen it
really does feel like these two crazy
otherworldly aliens are just fucking
killing each other it's awesome the
animation is spectacular it's the best
I've ever seen in a dragon ball anything
it's far better than the animation in
Dragon Ball super it's top tier
animation quality in regards to Dragon
Ball there's a few times where they use
CG for the human characters not just for
like ships and stuff and it's a little
noticeable but because of that they were
able to achieve greater fluid movement
with the fights and I was impressed by
that this is one of the first Dragon
Ball films where I genuinely want to see
happens next it actually sets up
something compelling it doesn't feel
like a one-off it feels like they really
are trying to create a narrative here
with characters that Dragon Ball fans
can like now I've said this in most of
my Dragon Ball movie reviews if you
weren't a fan of this franchise you're
not gonna know what the hell is going on
and it's not gonna have much of an
impact on you if you've never seen
anything Dragon Ball related before I
would highly recommend not watching this
because it's just gonna be lost on you
but for Dragon Ball fans this is gonna
give them everything they wanted it has
the fanservice moments but it has stuff
I didn't expect I actually found myself
caring about Broly and that's impressive
he had a plight that I related to and
that I understood and the fights oh my
fucking god best I've ever seen in
Dragon Ball seriously I mean it's not as
narrative ly compelling as the freezer
vs. Goku stuff because that's built up
over the course of ten thousand episodes
but this is in regards to movies easily
easily top tier best Dragonball movie
ever made I'm gonna give Dragon Ball
super Broly and a but like I said if
you're not already initiated with the
Dragon Ball franchise you're probably
not gonna appreciate most of this but if
you are it's gonna give you everything
you want I'm just happy I saw a movie
that I was looking forward to seeing
that I was excited about that was good
I'm just so happy about that
it feels like it's been a long time I
can take a breath of fresh air and feel
good about liking movies again for a
while guys thank you so much as always
for watching look forward to more
reviews very soon and as always if you
liked this you can click right here and
get steppen eyes
[Music]